Ready critics agree hawkeye is one
of the best shows on television
it's the most fun marvel adventure of the
year and the biggest surprises are yet to come
Who's that!
I've got your next target maybe you'd like a shot
at the man responsible for your sister's death
Welcome back everyone this will be my new marvel
hawkeye trailer video for yelena belova it seems
like they're finally teasing her on the show and
we're waiting to see when she's actually going to
show up it sounds like it's going to be pretty
soon so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the episodes i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which episode you think
she's going to show up in first but in this newest
hawkeye trailer video for the next few episodes i
think there's footage from the next few episodes
they tease the biggest surprises are yet to come
and then show you a bunch of new footage of his
fight with the tracksuits or his and kate
bishop's fight with the tracksuits it also
what looks like a scene of yelena belova wearing
ultra stealth black widow gear watching hawkeye
and kate bishop from a different rooftop and
her saying who the hell is that a couple of you
longtime comic book readers who are big fans of
the thunderbolts comics may have also recognized
that the costume that she's wearing the stealth
gear makes her look exactly like yelena belova's
thunderbolts stealth costume in the comics like
this is right out of a thunderbolts comic book
we've all been talking this entire year
about how julie louis dreyfus's character
val madame hydra the countess whatever you want
to call her has been slowly assembling what seems
like a thunderbolts team in the background of all
the marvel disney plus shows and marvel phase 4
movies so far like the black widow post-credits
scene then the falcon winter soldier with us
agent john walker there's all kinds of theories
about how the abomination from the shangshi movie
is somehow connected to val even though val
didn't have a cameo scene during that film
so to make the thunderbolt's connection to this
mystery figure the fact that it's one of the
biggest surprises that they're hyping up in the
hanging plot thread of yelena belova vs hawkeye
after the black widow post-credits scene it just
seems like the universe in marvel really want you
to think that this is her in the trailer i don't
know if this footage is specifically from episode
4 or if it's from episode 5 my assumption that
it would be like something from the later part
of episode 4 like early theory she might just show
up at the end of episode 4 in a short stinger wtf
cliffhanger type of scene and then be a bigger
character and get more scenes during episode 5.
big reminder too there are only six episodes
total so it's not like they can pull the taffy
on revealing her or anything or paying off this
hawkeye versus elena belova storyline things on
the show are supposed to escalate super fast from
zero to kingpin and yelena belova versus hawkeye
within a few episodes of each other there was some
other footage from an earlier promo with hawkeye
and kate bishop fighting this stealth character
on a similar looking rooftop so a couple weeks ago
people thought that that might have been yelena
belova and it does seem like a similar setup to
what's happening in this scene here with them
on the rooftops watching someone and then also
this mystery stealth figure who's probably yelena
belova also watching them there's still the whole
echo versus hawkeye and kate bishop's storyline
that just got started and she still believes that
kate bishop is ronin right now she doesn't want
to believe anything that hawkeye was telling her
about black widow getting rid of ronan that also
plays into the yelena belova storyline going after
hawkeye in a really interesting way that i'll
point out in a second too a lot of it has to
do with how much the public the general public of
the mcu just people walking around on the street
know about what really happened during avengers
end game but on her own ekko still wants revenge
for the death of her father believing that ronan
killed him and i know there are a lot of twisty
theories about how that could be a misdirect ronin
killing her father but without more context i do
think that the show really wants you to think
hawkeye actually killed her father he said and he
wasn't lying that he tore through the tracksuit's
upper management as ronin during that five-year
time jump and her father led the tracksuit's crew
before her so he was upper management at that time
now there is the uncle quote-unquote kingpin
character it seems like he was always at the
top and from what hawkeye said he never got the
chance to take him out when he was still ronin but
as for a connection between the kingpin plot val
and yelena belova thunderbolt's mission to kill
hawkeye a lot of you in the past have asked if val
is working with kingpin or kate bishop's mother
and that's the yelena belova connection like
someone on the show might know hawkeye secret
identity is ronin because if you re-watch
the black widow post-credits scene when val
gives yelena belova her next target just gives
her the pad it only has a picture of hawkeye in
his ronin costume with his mask off she doesn't
say hawkeye she doesn't say ronan she just says
the person responsible for her sister's
death and i think it's implied that yelena
belova knows who hawkeye is so it's like oh wow
hawkeye was responsible so i'm gonna go kill him
but the idea is that whoever actually is behind
the hit whoever ordered it knows that hawkeye was
ronin in on the show so far they've been treating
it like this huge mystery like nobody in the new
york city crime families knows who he is or at
least the low-level people that we've seen so far
the ronin brought a brutal form of justice to his
victims and his identity continues to remain a
mystery to this very day so it's always possible
that somebody at the upper level of the new york
city crime families the mob knows his secret
identity knows he was ronan and wants revenge
for him killing all the people in the new york
city mob families during that five year time jump
and they're just using val and the thunderbolts
team to do it so it's always possible there's a
connection there and you have to remember that
kate bishop's mother has all those security
cameras everywhere so if anybody was going to
get a snap of hawkeye with his mask off in the
ronin costume it could have been her but typically
different tv show plot lines like this that seem
totally different wind up being related somehow
by the finale like on the loki series for instance
there was the mystery of the tva pruning people
what was going on with that then separately the
mystery behind why all the tva agents themselves
were mind-wiped variants and then the explainer
for just how the multiverse worked in general in
the mcu they all seemed like different story lines
at first different threads that had nothing
to do with each other but by the end they all
wound up being connected through the reveal of
he who remains kang orchestrating everything the
whole time pulling the strings and creating this
false narrative to keep everybody in the dark so
don't be surprised if the person who ordered the
assassination attempt on hawkeye through val like
hiring val and yelena belova to do it creating the
fake story about hawkeye killing black widow to
mislead yelena belova is somehow connected to the
new york city mob wanting revenge on ronin killing
everyone during that five year time jump even
though it does seem like kingpin is really in the
shadows at the top pulling all the strings they're
still building to a big reveal of kate bishop's
mother and how she's connected to the mob and
has the tracksuit bros listed as her contractors
in the database and seemingly has this wide
surveillance net that seems like it's violating
a bunch of privacy laws all over the new york city
area like i said if somebody was going to catch a
secret snap of hawkeye as ronin with his mask off
it would probably be her with all that tech she
has embedded all over the city and if it wasn't
clear the fact that the tracksuit bros are listed
as contractors in her bishop security database
means that she is probably the one who ordered
the hit on the auction to steal the watch from
the avengers base but the big question is why she
would have done that what is the significance of
the watch who did it belong to and did she do that
on the orders of someone like kingpin let me know
in the comments though if you think that one of
the characters that we've already seen on the
show is behind the yelena belova hit on hawkeye
val is more of an intermediary in all this so even
though she does seem really sus she's mostly doing
this on the orders of someone else like somebody
ordered a hit and she's passing it along to yelena
belova as for how hawkeye versus yelena belova
is going to go down he's been having all these
ptsd flashbacks he still feels so much guilt over
the death of black widow he does feel responsible
for her death but he didn't kill her he did
everything he could to sacrifice himself like they
had a knock down drag out fight she won and that's
the reason why she died issues that whoever hired
val and yelena belova wants her to think that he
killed her to make it more likely that she would
follow through on the hit so early prediction
hawkeye and yelena belova fight for a while until
they're able to get her to listen to reason and he
explains what really happened on vormir and what
was really going on with black widow at the time
that made her want to sacrifice herself so badly
if it wasn't clear marvel wants you to
think that she wasn't just trying to save
her avengers family because she kept talking
about saving her family during that movie she
was also trying to bring back her russian family
too and i think it's implied that some of them
maybe even yelena belova herself got snapped like
red guardian and molina probably got snapped too
and that's why she wanted to sacrifice herself
so badly to make sure that they could come back
yelena belova wouldn't have any of that
information right now i explained this during
my episode 3 video too but it seems like kate
bishop all the other regular people of the mcu
just regular citizens don't know all the details
of what happened during the avengers end game time
heist mission so nobody else knows what really
happened on vermeer they only know about the
battle with thanos the avengers compound because
it was covered by the news so post all your yelena
belova theories on the video the showrunner said
that he actually had to beg marvel to include her
in the series like please this is so important for
hawkeye's storyline let me include this character
i'm not really expecting to see kingpin show up
if he does get a cameo scene till like episode
five or six it probably won't be till a little bit
later and the rumor is is it'll just be a really
quick small cameo scene and he'll be a bigger
character during the echo spin-off series as well
as charlie cox's daredevil character coming back
during the echo series my full hawkeye episode 4
video we'll post next wednesday just like normal
and i have some new spider-man no way home
videos i'll be posting soon and a dc peacemaker
trailer video with john cena congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last big hawkeye
video josh waistblatt please email me on the
back end of my channel so i can get your contact
details everyone click here for my new spider-man
no way home video with more tobey mcguire
and andrew garfield easter eggs and footage
and click here for my full hawkeye episode 3 video
with a whole bunch of daredevil and kingpin easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!